so click your name click background
click dark transparent
what does transparent it whoa it's
penguin what's going on
oh is this is transparent mood where
Magnus plays penguin I think this why
not let's go back to dark Magnus first
penguin one minutes I imitate magnet I
interview an anger tame just a few days
ago in Orlando I played the US Open and
now he's playing Magnus penguin Gian
against dr. night Justine 99 it's a
number been Feingold would be proud of
if Magnus wins the scheme it says 100 me
chest wind against and retain at least
on this accounts I'm sure he's played
and retaining on other accounts it's
crazy so crazy I just dropped something
nothing of importance though I will say
anti-tank is probably warned up but ok
he's losing here or is he
wait what's going on so Bachmann's a
piece but this pawn scary spawn is very
scary and this wreck is scary too and
the one thing about Andrew have
different from chess bra Andrew is
really fast like a monster fast chess
bra is pretty fast but Andrew is like
loosing boats of bullet chess this is
not easy to be Andrew you're down 10
seconds are up a bishop I would imagine
them yeah why it's just playing for a
win just go for the flag Carlsen strong
the piece it's too slow
it's like racing against Usain Bolt's
like you got a 20 meter head starts but
it doesn't matter
you're gonna lose unless you win no
you're in the loose ouch
so 99 still fur for dr. reichter's team
so that was the first game we're
catching the beginning of the match the
other Kings gambit Full Tilt's for
Magnus Center what does this g3 takes on
each two over up g2 loses the Knights
very bad opening for black so doc trying
to get counter play it's not gonna work
this is coming yeah the tricks just run
out that was Magnus Carlson's 100th wind
congratulations 102 39 a lifetime score
between these two accounts chess by Jay
welcome back just by Jay saying I
literally just resigned my current game
to watch this yeah this is worth
watching over over playing chess is 317
spectators I'm still really curious what
happens when I click this like who do I
a voice chat with with a voice chat with
all the spectators
there's 322 spectators on this game
there's a spectator room I think I'll
leave that hidden
thanks for now click it Eric you know
you want to
I'm just scared yeah I don't want like
the stream to become untreated by
hundreds of people with their voices I
know it's a new feature but too scared
so when I was playing the king scanned
it it's not something that we see too
often but he's playing it well I mean
he's not even down the pond yeah Bishop
takes hs7 probably didn't work there
knife i-5 incoming enough for who takes
h6 does that work takes takes
threatening stuff on each seven that
could work and you're too scared to
taken now he's suffering oh this is
looking very bad Kings gambit too strong
mm black going for tricks I need to
update the twitch level what's the
twitch title is up I spelled I think I
spell things correctly
oh but Andrew team is playing yeah let
me update the title what should I tell
this also I have mods I can update the
title for me right
okay ah chess pee loves titles I really
updated it hopefully that works tog II
says I play Kings gambit I'm 1,200
player yeah I'm sure there's people
watching to play the Kings gambit what
is going on it's a fun race
two-on-two penguin seems faster but
these pawns are disconnected these
phones are connected
it's a time scramble Andrew low on time
but Andrew super fast running mate g5
meets g5 mates og5 mates let's get some
g5 emotes in the chat that was beautiful
Andrew ting let Karlsson promotes but
had g5 meet with just Sorokin chiffons
and King was nasty love-hate chess is
love each I still in the chat luffy
chess would have liked that g5 me
doesn't happen every day how these
nights coming to g4 ooh this 54 ideas
now cuz takes takes these pawns can be
scary
that's my life goal checkmating Carlson
with g5 so nice I've never checked me
that Magnus I've only been in two times
one time actually both times he just
resigned I think it's not easy to check
Nate him I like the way Magnus is
playing but he's just too slow like it's
down on time
whew that was tricky move so blocks down
a piece now but has these pawns
seoulites acts back and now White's up a
pawn and on time
Wow yeah Angie Tang is gonna win this
the one thing that black has going for
him is these pawns are fixed on lakes
bears but he just fling a bishop so it
doesn't matter too weak too slow it's
rough in other Kings gambit Queen e2 is
Queen e2 we need to just like flocks of
bishop no each for free pawn for black
uh it was a trade that was nice
a white center actually looks pretty
immaculate I just freeze I think I just
froze there sorry about that
hey it's bits it's from Co her madness
just working his way up the Blitz
rankings yes in the tank then Daniel
then he paru and then rosin the bars
right I would be interesting
and Daniel I assume that Staniel near
this ski a kay Rebecca Harris I'm not
sure if I'll get to play but okay the
the doctor is thirty points away from
breaking mm I mean he's playing minute
andrew is higher rate than the Magnus
which I did not realize so this is a a
nice wave so matchup for Magnus more
rating points on the line this is gonna
be a draw this is hard to stop ooh
what's going on here is white just
losing I think weights losing you can't
stop Quinn a one you run out of chucks
f6 BAM Queen c7 take Queen age seven
King g7 resigns or no Queen c7 back and
then Bishop f7 yeah what was gonna run
out of checks that's rough d4 I was
hoping to see a London I defy we have a
weird opening again a Scandinavian
against d4 but Whitehouse Center pawns I
like the way entertain is playing good
center staying solid staying calm
ninety-eight undeveloped in this looks
kind of risky Queen takes and attack the
rook maybe know Angie's playing a really
nice skin here the King can't castle
yeah White was basically just amazing
that was really nice
okay this time we don't have a king scan
but we have an Italian D for maybe
before before it's playable he's gaining
space g5 early g5 you can get away with
this when you're not castled interesting
opening play both sides delay castling
h4 trying to undermine black structure
Mike goes back to where it came from the
redevelops Knight f1 interesting night
maneuvers by having some I sent your
pawns five things opening up at some
point white should probably play e4
Queen e3 maybe feels good when I
predicts Carlson's moves maybe taking
wreck f1 because blacks gonna try and
fight for that file what's going on
Magnus thinking for an eternity this is
not good
I just took like ten seconds there moist
of time boo Bishop d2 what a maneuver h6
you have to defend my barricade shade or
not
wow that's meats that was mates he had
to play rook eight shades what a meets
the bishop the Queen the other Bishop
the rook look at that good
so beautiful that's thumbnail worthy did
ting rage quits what's going on
maybe he rage quitted